good afternoon everyone how's the
conference going so walk so far great so
today I'm going to talk about how you
all can become data superheroes for
nonprofits in our area imagine that you
are a non-profit leader you are working
day and night to help people in my case
my organization we help people learn how
to use technology you've been collecting
data for years and years you have to
collect it you have to report to your
funders and in your annual report who
you're serving and how you're serving
them but you know that there's so much
more that you can do you know that there
are stories that your data tells that
you just can't quite figure out what do
you do that's exactly the position that
bite back was in of about a year ago
when we looked at our large set of data
that we've been collecting for years and
years and so today I'm going to talk
about how we were able to overcome that
problem and how you all can help other
organizations to do the same bite back
is a non-profit we are based in DC and
we work primarily with DC residents and
our mission is to improve economic
opportunity by providing computer
training and career services to
underserved residents of our region and
so what that means is that we provide
classes two people two adults and teach
them how to use technology we meet
people where they are which means that
we have hundreds of people every year
who come through our doors who don't
know how to use a mouse who don't know
how to navigate a home screen we also we
then help that those individuals move up
our training pathway so some of our
students start at that beginner level
others might come in at our intermediate
level or into our advanced
industry-recognized certification
classes in addition to providing that
training which is one of the core
service we provide we also help people
to find jobs
jobs and IT and jobs that use technology
are some of the few careers out there
where people can get training over six
months or a year and move into a living
wage job you don't necessarily need a
college degree to find a job that helps
you to support your families and so
that's really you know the second part
that the second part of our work we help
people use the tech skills get
certifications that employers are
looking for and then we link them with
jobs and then the third part of our work
is referrals we work with students and
I'll talk about this a little later who
face significant challenges around
housing around food around even being
able to afford transportation and so we
refer our students to other services
other social services because that's not
one of the services we provide so that's
at a high level what biteback does bite
back was founded in 1997 and I think
it's amazing that our co-founders in
1997 saw the importance of technology
that technology provides a pathway to to
working-class people to low-income
people into the middle class and into
living wage careers so they thought they
they came up with this term fight back
and they then it fight back inspired
bite back fight back started we were
tiny tiny neighborhood organization
based out of a rural house and northeast
DC where we still actually are
headquartered and we were just working
with a few people over the past seven or
eight years we've grown exponentially
and now since 2009 over 7,000 students
have come through our door so over seven
thousand adults primarily who live in DC
have come to us with with help to get
help around technology and our students
and again I'll talk about this little
more are so inspiring because many of
them don't have stable homes are
struggling to pay the rent and yet they
come to bite back to make their lives
better and I think it's so
amazing as over the past 10 years as
technology has become more and more
critical to our lives we've seen bite
back grow and it's a little
counterintuitive because we use we all
use technology every second of the day
and unfortunately even though technology
has become more important in our lives
the digital divide has not necessarily
been shrinking at least among the people
who bite back works with so we see
increased numbers of people coming
through our doors desperate to get
technology technology skills in last
year in 2015 2016 we had 854 course
enrollments we taught 93 classes we had
students from across DC but as you can
see northeast and southeast DC which are
primarily the most low-income Ward's of
the city that's where most of our
students come from seventy-five percent
of our students use the skills that they
learn at bite back to search for new
jobs I'll never forget I was going
shopping in Columbia Heights and I
passed the new chick-fil-a it wasn't yet
opened and it said we're hiring apply
online so even for those jobs that we
consider to be relatively low skilled
you have to be able to not only access a
computer with internet you have to be
able to navigate a web form and a lot of
our students come through our doors not
able to do that one of my favorite
things about the work that we do it bite
back is that I think we are really
challenging the idea of what the tech
world looks like and I know that there
was a lunch on diversity that many of
you just came from and I I think that's
so critical because there are there's so
much untapped potential in this country
of people and talent to contribute to
the tech world and so again our students
are coming to us not really fitting the
mold of what we think of when we think
of tech workers sixty-seven percent of
our students last year received
government benefits almost thirty
percent were homeless
or they didn't have secure housing so
they were living in a car they were
living with a friend or a family member
who could kick them out at any time we
had a student last year who was coming
to our certification classes he was in
our advanced classes and he was living
in a storage unit that's what our
students that's what our students are
struggling with and they're still coming
to bite back and doing really well and
moving into tech jobs I think it's
amazing seventy-four percent of our
students last year were unemployed we
see a wide range of students last year
from the age of 17 to 88 years old
almost all of our students are people of
color most black african-american or
Latino and something I'm very proud of
is that almost fifty percent of our
students last year were women which is
compared to about twenty-five percent of
of the percentage of women working in
tech so I think that's really awesome so
what do our students learn when they
come to bite back they are getting
skills that are both really transforming
how they interact with the world and are
able to participate in the world as well
as getting skills that are helping them
to move in to move into jobs for our PC
for beginners class which is our very
very basic class our students come in
they in order to be to determine if our
students go into intermediate or
beginner we give a very simple
assessment that assessment is they have
to create a word document that has their
name on it save it to save it to their
death a desktop or wherever save it on
the computer and then email it to one of
our staff many many people of our
students cannot pass that and so then
they're placed into the pc for beginners
class so the beginner of a pc for
beginners class our students don't know
how to send an email and by the end of
the class it's a six week class our
students can send a job resume as an
email attachment which is amazing now
they're able to actually apply for a job
our intermediate level class which we
call off this track is really focused on
getting our students more comfortable
with the Microsoft Office suite
in that class they come in they've never
seen Microsoft Excel and they leave the
class where they can create graphs
charts presentations using Excel and
PowerPoint and then we have our our
advanced what we call advanced
certification classes so they in those
classes our students go from having a
rudimentary knowledge of Excel to being
able to use formulas for tasks and to
troubleshoot building formulas if RA
plus certification class which is the
certification for people who are
interested in going into jobs as a IT
help desk specialist for example they
come in not really having an
understanding of hardware and finish
being able to build a computer from
scratch and really being able to
troubleshoot so these skills are really
again transformative from what they they
came in with before and what I'm most
proud of I think having new skills is
amazing but what I'm most proud of is
the amazing outcomes that we see my
favorite statistic is that for our
students who come in and don't have a
job and this is specifically our
advanced certification students and then
are hired into a job so last year we had
53 graduates who were hired into living
wage jobs their incomes went up for
yearly 28 thousand dollars so from that
very first year they are making 28
thousand dollars more than they were
before so when we think about what are
the things thank you we just
think about how that can totally change
someone's life ninety-six percent of our
students said that they were more
skilled than than before I don't know
who those four percent were but and all
of our students I've ever talked to and
and the vast majority of them Express an
increase in their overall
self-confidence as you think about going
from living in a world where you see
everyone using their phones to call an
uber using email to communicate to their
co-workers being at work and not being
able to use a computer when your
co-workers can it really changes
people's a sense of self and the sense
of sense of potential that they have so
that's bite back and that some of our
data and I think about when I I joined
by back a year ago and and I think a
year ago bite back was very similar to a
lot of nonprofits in the way that we use
data so there was a 2016 survey of
nonprofit staff it was called this the
state of data in the nonprofit sector
and what they found is ninety percent of
the survey respondents said that they
were collecting collecting data you
can't get funding unless you report on
basic outcomes a lot of foundations for
example we'll ask how many students did
you serve stuff like that everybody's
doing that what I find really
interesting is only forty-nine percent
of the survey respondents knew how their
organization was collecting data so
people know that they're collecting it
but they don't really know how that's
happening what are the systems that are
being utilized and then only five
percent of the respondents said that
they use data in every decision they
make so I think this is very typical we
are collecting the data we're not really
sure how it's working we're not really
understanding how to use it and then
we're probably not using it very much
because of that so why aren't more
nonprofits using data ninety-seven
percent of the survey respondents said
they're interested in using it more
which i think is great we're starting
from
where we really understand how important
data is but why aren't we using it so
when I came to bite back a year ago we
were using a database that I had never
heard of called orvind and then but
because we didn't really know how to use
it we were also collecting data in Excel
it was a mess so we have data in Excel
over here then we have some data in or
Bund in order to ever pull it like we
would pull the data out of urban but
then we would have students that were
being tracked into different systems we
didn't know we didn't have the tools and
then I think the other really
significant barrier is that a lot of
nonprofit staff just don't have a lot of
experience using data nonprofit leaders
come from all different backgrounds
there are people who are lawyers they're
people who didn't go to college there
people who are social workers I have a
master's in public affairs and so we
just it's not a requirement that we have
experience using data and I think a lot
of people are kind of nervous about it I
came from a non-profit where we did use
data I'm also married to a statistician
and economist so I'm not scared of it
but that's not that's not typical and
then the other really significant issue
is that we just don't have enough time
or money to pay for it it was a big
sacrifice for bite back to hire I dated
an evaluation manager and I'm so glad we
did and he came to this conference
yesterday and he loved it but it's a
decision we have we all have limited
resources and so for most nonprofits if
you're deciding between hiring a data
person and hiring someone who's going to
provide direct services to your
participants it's it's pretty hard to
make a decision not to hire that person
who's going to be directly working with
your participant so these are these are
the reasons I mean these are real these
are real reasons it's not because
nonprofits aren't interested or
understand the value so what can we do
we had an amazing experience getting a
team of data scientists and engineers to
help us to understand our date
and that's what I want to spend the rest
of my time here talking to you about we
were very lucky that we found out about
a program through a data company called
apt which is a master card company we
heard that they were accepting
applications from nonprofits to do a
24-hour data dive and we said this
sounds amazing let's do it and we
applied and we were selected and so this
spring we had the opportunity to have a
team of 60 people at this company
combing through our data from over from
the previous five years and it has been
completely transformative for us and how
we're doing our work so I want to talk
about that so that is our you know this
was our superhero move that helped us
move from that we're collecting the data
to really understanding and using it so
how does a dated I've work for in this
example we had this amazing team at apt
who had access to our data we spent many
months collecting it and combing through
it and sending it over to them so they
had our data and they took 24 hours to
answer a set of questions about bite
back and about our impact the team was
very collaborative and cross-functional
so there were data scientists working
with marketing people working with
mapping experts all together looking at
these questions there were no required
or expected tools that they were
bringing they use their tools that they
had available to them as in the company
and they use data analytics and
technical skills and they had a singular
focus of looking at the questions that
we had come up with and saying how can
we help biteback understand the answers
to these questions so that we could make
more that so that we can make more
impact for our students so the setting
up for the data dive was pretty
time-intensive about two months before
the dive started we decided on three key
questions that could be answered we
actually ended up answering for we
talked about what were the data we had
available to us that could answer those
questions
and then we sent them data from for
years there were three thousand three
hundred student records and apt used
about a third of those we they linked
are some of the data we had Excel with
the data that we now have in Salesforce
I'm very proud to say we actually use
Salesforce it is our database and we're
not having like 10 different databases
now so they linked those two things and
they identified gaps we had a lot of
back and forth to make sure that our
data was usable so about two weeks
before the data dive the apt the apt
team worked and loaded all of our data
into their platforms they created a
high-level plan how are they going to
approach this and then they had three
teams of 20 people who spent 24 hours
really doing a deep predictive analysis
of the four questions we came up with
and so in those 24 hours they dug deep
into the questions and then presented us
the results the next day they used they
have a lot of proprietary software I
asked if they use Python they did but
they use their test and learn software
they did statistical regressions they
made some models from Excel and they
have a third-party software formatting
the four questions that we looked at
were which types of biteback students
are most likely to drop out of our
classes which types of students were
most likely to pass or re-enroll into
future classes so those are our
classroom success we wanted to see what
are the characteristics of the students
who are struggling so we can figure out
ways to help them more and what are the
characteristics of the students who are
doing really well we also looked at
employment success which applicants are
most likely to succeed so which fight
back graduates or participants are most
likely to move into jobs and then the
fourth question was where should we
locate our classes we teach all
throughout DC and every Ward so it was
very it's very interesting for us to
understand where we should be finding
places to teach
the data dive used a wealth of data and
I'm very proud that we had this was the
they do this a few times a year and our
data set was the richest data set they
had so they were able to really dig in
and that's why the team was so large
they looked at one of the
characteristics of our instructors what
how our students attending are they
attending class which types of classes
are students leaving they looked at end
of class surveys that we give they
looked at our completion rates they
looked at outcomes around employment
around how students were reporting using
computers and looked at where we had
taught and the success of those class
locations so they really looked at
basically everything we could we could
throw at them they looked at it so what
did they find it was really interesting
what they found what they found some of
it made sense and some of it was a
little surprising to us they found that
in this makes sense when you think about
it but we never thought about it this
way that those students who have stable
homes do better so the students who come
to us and have a job and maybe it's part
time or maybe it's full time but who
have a job do end up completing
completing better like they could plead
at higher rates and that's a little
counterintuitive because you think about
someone balancing and juggling a job and
coming to bite back and being with their
families and all the stuff that life
throws at you but yet those students who
do have a job are doing better students
who are older tend to complete their
classes that have a higher percentage
rate of completing by back classes and
students who live in our own home do
better so students who have that
stability are really able to focus more
at bite back and so that tells us
something about where we invest our
resources it tells us that we really
need to be continuing to build
partnerships to link our students with
those types of services to help them
have a stable life students is very
interested in interesting students with
postgraduate education
so who have a bachelor's degree and went
beyond that that actually don't do as
well we're not really sure why we think
that maybe we're not meeting their needs
maybe they have a different type of need
maybe our classes are not are too easy
so they're dropping out maybe they're
going to find work and then female
students are actually doing better
controlling for other factors for the
classroom location analysis they looked
at two things one they looked at they
looked at 53 biteback locations across
the city and they said and what
locations are the students most likely
to complete and pass the class and move
on to jobs and then they looked at what
are the locations in DC that are
underserved where there aren't a lot of
resources like bike back for students
and so the nexus between these two areas
we determined would be the optimal
classroom location because we know that
the students will be coming in the
coming two classes in those communities
would will be successful and there's
need there and so apt mapped though the
entire city for us and showed us
potential locations where where we
believe our students will will do really
well and that's great we're using this
all the time to figure out where to
locate our next set of classes so just
to summarize we now know thanks to this
data dive that stable housing is
extremely important that enrolling our
students in the right difficulty level
is extremely important and that we know
that older students for example are more
likely to complete the class so we need
to think about how are we reaching out
to younger students to make sure that
they have the resources they need to
finish we know that students who are
employed beforehand do better so we can
work with them definitely to move into
jobs but then what are the additional
services we need to provide to
unemployed students to make sure that
they can also succeed and we also know
thanks to this analysis that classes in
northeast and southeast DC and specific
neighborhoods are going to be effect
places for us to offer our classes and
we're actually bite back is actually
moving into new headquarters and so this
finding is also helping us to determine
where we should how's our operations so
I think this was it was such an amazing
experience we really there were
assumptions that we were disproved for
us and it really is the first time that
we are able to make these types of
decisions not just based on anecdotes or
kind of what we what we into it but make
it based on real data and as we look
forward we have already started using
this data in many ways like I said we're
using the mapping data we now are able
to look at students when they come in
and determine which ones we think are a
little more high-risk and make sure that
our instructors are spending extra time
with those students so now apt was our
superhero but I want to give a charge to
all of you to also become data
superheroes and there's so many ways
that you can do that one is to think
about leading a similar data dive at
your company or your organization there
DC has the highest per capita number of
nonprofits in the country there are so
many organizations out there who could
so benefit from having an experience
like that so like this and please feel
free to reach out to me and I'd be happy
to also connect you all to folks at apt
to talk a little bit more about this so
that's one way that you can that you can
become a superhero another way is to
volunteer with a non-profit like I said
Jackie is on our board she's the reason
I'm here she is amazing and so there's
so many ways to volunteer for nonprofits
a bite back for example we're always
looking for board members we're looking
for people to help teach our classes to
tutor to come in and talk to our
students about your careers and there's
just such a need its can be so helpful
to for participants inconsistence at
nonprofits to meet people who are doing
the amazing work that you're doing
mentoring is another one
derful way to support an organization
like buyback or other nonprofits our
students really benefit from being able
to talk to people who have careers and
really understand how do you navigate a
career how do you succeed in an
interview how do you network things that
we all often take for granted are not
are not that obvious to people who've
never had a chance to have a
white-collar job so that's another way
and then of course because i'm a
nonprofit executive director we all love
money so donate so there's so many
there's so many ways that you all can be
superheroes and I need to close this
first asking for questions but then
second asking my daughter I'll be
thanking my daughter Ella for letting me
borrow her cape and she loves
superheroes and that's her at Disneyland
last week in the Jedi training academy
so I'm very proud of her um so any
questions and thank you so much
you know it's a great question so I
don't but I can definitely reach out to
the folks at apt and ask them and I'm
sure they would be happy to talk with
anyone who's interested in that so I can
definitely do that sure so one of the
assumptions we had was that folks who
were on government benefits maybe that
they would have a different outcomes
than we would have assumed maybe they
would be doing better maybe they would
be doing worse and what we found is that
actually didn't have a huge impact so
folks who were getting food stamps we're
doing about the same as everyone else so
that was really that was really
interesting I think we had a we had an
idea that it was hard for students who
had a job to really juggle coming to
bite back and working and that was
totally not true like it was it was the
opposite that students who had a job who
have a job actually do better so those
were some of them that were just very
interesting for us to see kind of
question what's the tech the strategy
going forward to evaluate these data
questions again and and keep on top of
the data collection and so on and so
forth absolutely that's a great question
so like I said we're so excited we hired
someone who is a data person and we now
collect all of our data on salesforce so
we I mean even this corridor we just I
just met with my senior management team
it was the first time in a year that we
were able to have quarterly data like
ready we were able to see how many
students have already been placed in a
job in this first quarter so we have
totally revamped how we're collecting
data and then we are in touch with apt
on a regular basis and hope that you'll
at the end of this year will be able to
send them over some data and see if we
can if we see any differences in our
outcomes or in the characteristics of
students who are succeeding
I'm going to go ahead and cut this off
shore but Elizabeth will be here
afterwards yes and I have one
announcement to make sure Elizabeth does
not know about this but last weekend
capital one hosted a hackathon banking
with humanity and one of the prizes we
gave out was to allow the winning teams
to each give ten thousand dollars to one
of our nonprofit partners and two of the
winning team selected thank you all we
have a break now next session starts at
two fifteen and there's my email address
is not on there it is a Lindsay about
that dog you find it on our website and
I have cards thank you so much this was
some